hello Karen warden with film crews the
radio show we're here with attorney
filmmaker and author of Paul Bautista
and we're kind of we keep on me know
guarded we don't want to let people know
because we're afraid that they'll turn
around we don't know who we're talking
to you sometimes on the street or who
can overhear us and then they might turn
it into something and make a ton of
money you know and it's a common it's a
common question and there's a few
different schools of thought from the
people that are within the system that
I've seen respond to it their answer is
always like just as many ideas as you
possibly can write them down you don't
sit on any one idea you should have as
many ideas as possible and expose them
to as many people as possible they do
leave out the other part that it is good
to protect yourself the other side of
the coin is ok I have all these ideas
and have them written down and I'm very
free with people that I meet how do I
protect myself and you know one way that
people do protect themselves is when
they're working with someone they're
going to pitch them out of here they say
look if you're going to use the idea I
would expect that I would be compensated
for and at that point they're trying to
create a contract with the person so
it's not based on copyright tues
or you know ideas are not copyrightable
first of all and then in terms of
getting it down into writing is a second
part of copyright but if you have
contracted someone you see look I'm
giving you something that's valuable and
if you use that that value I would
expect to be compensated for it you're
trying to create a contract the issue
then becomes how would you prove it down
the line and feedback that from the
attorney side that they offer here as
well follow up you know especially
nowadays with email if you send email
just recapping you know it's great to
meet you too great to see you you know
here's the idea talked about and you
know I hope things go great with it and
we'll figure out a good way to make
money off of this you they have a record
of the conversation who was with and
ultimately your side of what was said
normally people will respond that to
that email and say that's great to see
you or if they don't then it's still
your side of the record so it's a
difficult question because you as you
understand you want to come across as
paranoia later returned people off
because ultimately is about business but
on the other hand
pretty straight and ultimately you do
want to protect yourself how would you
deal with someone that says you know
what let's just have a gentlemen's
agreement on a handshake it's all fine
you can trust me don't worry about it
wouldn't steer you wrong what do you say
to that how does one say you know what I
do trust you but what if we just get
that in writing I mean it is an oral
contract binding or contracts in
California are binding the problem is
proving them because basically need to
have definite terms you need to
understand what the people were agreeing
to and that's really
the famous quote is over contracts are
worth the paper so yes they are but
ultimately I think that the answer is
when people do business they they want
to be clear so people's memory change
for good and bad so really that's great
that we trust each other but it's not a
matter of trust a matter of getting
clear and writing down even just basic
points of what we're agreeing to because
when you think of contracts you know if
you see like a studio contract 60 100
pages long and that's what comes to mind
but even a one-page two-page contract is
is better than just agreeing orally to
what that you're going to do you know
just if you get a one or two page
contract
their way to go and in terms of I say
that in terms of doing business a lot of
people do with the handshake those just
that's the way they do business in the
industry and would basically what
they're saying is that i'm going to
shoulder a certain amount of risk and at
the end of that if it doesn't turn out
the way I want to I'm not going to be
angry or upset I may protect myself all
those ways sending emails I mean emails
because really kind of change the game
in that way where you can follow up a
mountain and emails are written and
ultimately they won't be look to in
terms of trying to figure out what was
going on between parties so I would my
feedback would be from a practical what
if you utilize that email especially
because you can be informal yet talk
about the terms that you're you're
talking about to get to what is the
agreement that we have i have here his
book independent film producing the
outsiders guide to producing a first
low-budget feature film and you can get
that on Paul Bautista top is